Moin, hallo Leute, spontaner Streben, vielleicht sollte ich mein Glas hier nicht hinstellen, wo das Mauskabel ist, es könnte gefährlich werden, Monka Shake, irgendwie zeigt mir mein Twitch nichts an, was ist da los?
Okay, Sound ist synchron, das muss ich gerade nochmal nachgucken, man weiß ja nie, da guckt man, der Jax ist auch am Start, so, mal gucken, wie lange ich das Game heute aushalte.
Die Dinger können runterfallen? Moment, Moment, die Dinger können runterfallen? Wusstet ihr, dass die Dinger runterfallen können? Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Nicht aktiviert, Psychological, ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich mir nicht ein Better Twitch TV Abo hole, das kostet ja nicht viel, irgendwie 2 Dollar oder so.
Irgendwie zeigt mir Twitch keine Zuschauer.
Was ist da los? Was ist da los? Jetzt, so, auf geht's.
Heute, heute können wir zusammen spielen, wie gesagt, muss eh noch Quickplay machen bis Level 25, also wer mitspielen will, kann mitspielen, wo du merkst, Quickplay, nein, da muss ich klicken, ich habe voll den Reflex dazu klicken, ne.
Habt ihr was im Cyber Monday?
Amazon gekauft, Amazon Cyber Monday Woche, also diesmal war für mich, glaube, 2 Sachen habe ich gekauft, ansonsten war nichts dabei, ja, bis 21 Uhr ist eh Schluss.
So, warten wir mal ab, was die Leute picken.
Oh, irgendwie war heute anstrengend, ich muss erstmal wieder richtig, richtig hier wieder, jetzt mal so reinfinden in das Ganze.
Du spielst wieder Overwatch, ja, seit, ich habe mir gestern einen neuen Account gemacht, es kann aber gut sein, Mercy Main, by the way, es kann aber gut sein, dass mir das Game nach 3 Runden rankt, wieder so auf den Sack geht.
Kein Knopf bei Max, ja, gibt's doch nicht.
Also ich, diese Affiliate-Geschichte will ich gar nicht machen, also wenn schon, dann warte ich, bis ich konstant Viewer habe und dann mache ich Twitch, ähm, Partner, sage ich mal, dann gibt's nämlich auch ordentlich Emotes und alles, bei Affiliate ist ja so, so light alles irgendwie, ne.
Irgendwie habe ich so eine scheiß Haltung gerade, dass ich überhaupt nicht richtig die Maus bewegen kann.
Und ich brauche mal ein neues Mauspad.
Ich habe von, ich habe hier ein Rocket Hero, wo Rocket am Anfang gesagt hat, das kriegst du nie kaputt.
Soll ich euch mal was sagen, was das Problem ist, warum ich ein neues brauche?
Es ist kaputt, lol.
Warte, Moment, warum hat es nicht an mir gesaugt?
Ich wollte, die geben mir keinen Charge.
Kein Charge, kein Charge für den Max.
Auf, Pusherino, guck auf.
Die wollen mich, bah, die wollen mich nicht hauen, gibt's nicht.
Äh, ich muss Game Sound leiser machen, okay, mach ich.
Oh, fuck, fuck, gleich.
Hallo, Roadhog.
Oh, nee, jetzt habe ich ihn nicht angeklickt.
Ich muss erst mal aufmachen.
Ich mache Game Sound gleich leiser.
Zu laut?
Mach ich, mach ich.
Game Sound leiser.
Ist jetzt besser?
Ist jetzt, okay.
Jetzt, Pusher.
Oh, ich bin so kaputt noch.
Ich brauche jetzt bestimmt erst mal zwei, drei Runden, bis ich halbwegs wach bin.
Siehste, warum habe ich da kein Schild gedrückt, Max?
Warum habe ich da kein Schild gedrückt?
Was soll das?
Hätte ich instant Schild drücken müssen.
Jetzt aber.
Nope.
Was macht der da, die Mercy?
Hast du...
Hast du das mit Tippi-Stream mitgekriegt?
Nee, wieso, was ist da?
Was ist...
Fuck.
Was ist, was ist mit Tippi-Stream?
Was ist mit Tippi-Stream?
Was ich gemacht habe, da bin ich so kaputt.
Ich habe gearbeitet bis eben.
Den holen wir uns.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Heal, please.
Danke.
Wo ist...
Oh, Alter.
Das gibt es doch nicht.
Der Payload.
Juckt keinen.
Payload.
Scheiß drauf.
Who cares?
Payload.
Lol.
Okay, ich hau ab.
Hallo?
Disengage.
Nope.
Oh, ich muss erst mal aufwachen.
Richtig schlimm.
Gibt es in Overwatch viele Cheater?
Nö.
Gar nicht.
Also, man sieht da dran.
Zarya Solo.
Gar nicht.
Gibt in Overwatch quasi keine Cheater.
Was?
XML?
Was für ein Injection übers Nachrichtenfeld muss ich mir gleich machen?
Ich muss das mal durchlesen wegen Tippi-Stream.
Der Soldier möchte verrecken, oder?
Moment, kann man das nicht löschen?
Was ist denn hier los?
Dev.
Was ist hier wieder?
Oh, ne, Moment, hier ging es ja gar nicht hoch.
Ich bin voll verwirrt noch.
Wollt ihr nicht zurück?
Ich vergesse meine Raketen.
Warum vergesse ich immer meine Raketen?
Ich darf meine Raketen nicht vergessen.
Mach ich viel mehr Damage.
Echt?
Oh.
Huge Rats.
Ich muss weg.
Es klappt ja hier gar nichts.
Ähm.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Was?
Musste gleich nochmal schreiben, was mit Tippi-Stream ist und Injection und sowas.
Ja, was ist mit dem Link?
Warum kann ich Moiras Kugel nicht fressen?
Was?
Page not found?
Ihr verwirrt mich gerade.
Wie soll mich denn jemand über ein HTML-Textfeld hacken?
Soll denn das funktionieren?
Das muss ich...
Ich muss erstmal angucken, ob da was dran ist.
Ähm.
Das, was in das Feld geschrieben wird, ausgeführt.
Ach so.
Du meinst quasi, dass jemand in dem Feld was einträgt und das wird dann...
Clip Hacker.
Okay, das guck ich mir jetzt mal an.
Hä?
Hey, da führt irgendwie einer Sound aus.
Jetzt bin ich rausgetappt.
Jetzt Overwatch abgekackt.
Super.
Ne, ich habe jetzt keine Zeit, mich damit zu beschäftigen.
Ich meine, ich habe Donations eh nicht an.
Gerade, da sehe ich eh nichts.
Aber...
Also, ich wüsste nicht, wie das gehen soll.
Wie irgendjemand mich hacksen soll über ein HTML-Feld.
Zumal es doch nicht mal ein Browser ist oder so.
Hä?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das einzige, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, was funktionieren kann...
Also, was funktionieren könnte...
Ist, wenn jemand in das Donation-Feld was Manipuliertes reinschreibt, was dann mein OBS ausführen würde.
Das könnte sein.
Also sprich, wenn das OBS-Zeug verbuggt ist, das liegt dann aber nicht an Tippi's Stream, sondern das würde dann an OBS liegen.
Wenn quasi jemand in das Feld da was Manipuliertes reinschreibt und mein OBS das irgendwie nicht richtig escapt, was auch immer, und dann da Dinger ausführt.
Das könnte sein.
Ach, dieser Kram, der die Nachricht vorliest.
Ja, das könnte auch sein.
Ach so.
Ja, das kann natürlich sein.
Dieses...
Du meinst dieses Text-to-Speech-Ding?
Ja, das könnte...
Das könnte sein.
Wenn dieses Text-to-Speech-Ding quasi Text passt und das nicht richtig escapt und dann Scheiße baut.
Das kann passieren.
Ja, das kann sein.
Das kann sein.
Übrigens, äh, gestern hat noch lionabomber97 donated für 2,30€ und sagt, wenn ich im Saarland bin, soll ich im Klo-Boss einen Fleischkäse wegkaufen.
Hab ich erst danach gefuttert.
Ähm, ja, non-but-happy, kannst du machen.
Bis ich 25 bin, kann jeder mitspielen.
Ähm, was, äh, Two Lost Soldiers, hast du schon mal Android mit Firebase Backend-Services programmiert?
Zum Beispiel Firebase, äh, äh, Datenbank-mäßig?
Nö.
Nee, hab ich schon nie gemacht.
Was ist das denn da für ein Comp?
Qua-Quad-DPS-Meta?
Egal.
Quad-DPS-Meta, auf geht's.
Äh, ja, Halbcore, hab ich das jetzt ungefähr so gemacht?
Ja.
Ich hab das jetzt ungefähr so, äh, erklärt, wie, wie, wie, wie du das meintest.
Mit dem Injection.
Wow.
Was ist denn hier los?
Auf, Genji, komm her.
Ah!
Wer stirbt eigentlich hier gerade?
Hallo?
Okay, wir sterben.
Achtung, jetzt kommt hier Huge-Old, Huge-Old.
Krass.
Perfekt.
Super gelaufen.
Okay, wir machen doch nicht Quad-DPS.
Haha.
Was war deine Höchstplatzierung?
Also, letzte Season, wo wir Placement-Matches gemacht haben, irgendwie 3900, das war das
letzte.
Aber ich hab zuvor ja auch das letzte Mal Season 4 gespielt.
Also, ich bin wirklich nimmer gut.
Und der Genji lebt noch.
Meine Raketen!
Ich vergesse immer meine Raketen.
Warum kann man eigentlich das Moira-Ding nicht fressen?
Hahaha.
Lul.
Was war das?
Zu viel D.Va in your face.
Easy, sagte der McCree.
Wie ist dein Battletag?
Schreib mal deinen Battletag in den Chat.
Da erinnere ich dich, wie er eben runtergefallen ist.
Aber das mit diesem, um nochmal zurückzukommen auf dieses über...
Das ist dann wirklich kein Problem von Tippi's Stream, sondern...
Sprich mir das überhaupt so aus.
Sondern von diesem Tag to Speech.
Ähm...
Programm.
Das kann aber echt sein.
Also das ist theoretisch zumindest möglich.
Dass mich irgendjemand über ein HTML-Feld-Hackswort...
Eher nicht.
Sam Fischer ist...
Ist Dings...
Abo...
Sehe ich gerade.
Äh...
Wie heißt er?
Was ist das für ein Channel, Sam?
Ist das Dings hier...
Iron Aids ist das, oder?
Warum kann ich Moiras Kugeln einschnitten?
Rekt!
Wuhui!
Oh!
Sleep!
Sauerei!
Was soll das hier?
Why Sleep?
Hä?
Biss...
Bisschen over-extended?
Kann das sein?
Biss...
Bisschen over-extended?
So ein bisschen so...
So ein bisschen...
So ein kleines bisschen over-extended.
Das Text to...
Text to Speak Feature ist ein Feature von Tippi.
Na, das kann dann aber eigentlich auf meinem Rechner nichts ausführen.
So.
Ah!
Woran programmierst du gerne in deiner Freizeit?
Ähm...
An nem Notizprogramm mit Editor.
Bastel ich grad ein bisschen rum.
Nicht, nicht, dass die Welt noch mehr Editoren gebraucht hätte oder so, ne?
So ordentlich Regroupen.
Okay, das war keine gute Ult.
Nein!
Anna!
Gibt's nicht.
Tippi hatte getwittert, dass sie einen Bug hatten und ihn gefext haben.
Okay.
Kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ein Text to Speech Feature auf Tippi-Seite dazu führt,
dass bei mir irgendwas ausgeführt wird.
Ah!
Man weiß nicht.
Jetzt geht's ab.
So.
Jetzt aber.
Ist er wach?
Hattest du schon Pupke ausprobiert?
Pup...
Ja, ist nicht mein Fall.
Achtung, Achtung, Jungs.
Hehehe.
Da verreckt auch noch einer dran.
Was?
Oh, Mann!
Jetzt bin ich ausgerechnet da unten hingegangen, wo die Diva steht.
Da steht nie ne Diva.
Was macht die da?
Nee, oder?
Hohohoho.
Also, Pupke ist nicht mein Fall.
Was?
Oh, Mann!
Jetzt bin ich ausgerechnet da unten hingegangen, wo die Diva steht.
Da steht nie ne Diva.
Was macht die da?
Nee, oder?
Hohohoho.
Was macht die da?
Nee, oder?
Wo ist die Diva?
Okay, die Diva ist in meinem Fall.
Pupke ist nicht so meins.
Ich weiß auch nicht.
Das, an sich...
Ich habe halt ein Problem gegen Spiele, die nicht richtig funktionieren.
Ich bin da...
Ich glaube, ich habe da zu wenig...
Puh.
Hehehehe.
Ahem.
Ich habe da irgendwie zu wenig Toleranz, irgendwie für so... für Games, die sich
so unfertig und kaputt anfühlen.
Gegen das Spielprinzip von Pupke habe ich gar nix.
Aber Pupke fühlt sich halt...
so anpolisht an einfach so so unfertig und es gibt spiele die sind auch in der beta schon rund
oder runder zumal es ist jetzt nicht sogar offiziell raus wollten wir uns sollte das
nicht offiziell jetzt rauskommen sollte popke nicht erscheinen jetzt aber mir fällt es echt
schwer zu streben nach der arbeit wieso kaputt soll jetzt ende des jahres kommen na gut da haben
sie ja noch einen monat zeit aber ich meine das game ist jetzt nicht fertig warum soll das in
dem monat wenn es dann quasi in anführungsstrichen offiziell erscheint fertig sein ob japan endlich
ich habe mich schon drauf gefreut weil wir die erste zu sieben spielen dürfen 17 dezember irgendwie
das problem ist so bei vielen early access spielen die haben das ist genau das was
gegenteil finde ich wie es bei manchen triple a spiel das war ein triple a spiel habe ich das
gefühl man macht es einfach nur weil man jetzt mal wieder was machen muss dafür ist die technische
umsetzung meistens ganz okay und viele early access spiele haben eigentlich grundlegende
ganz gute idee aber die technische umsetzung ist oftmals scheiße und wird auch nicht fertig und
die beste idee bringt einem nichts wenn die umsetzung
komplett für den arsch ist spielen wir dann hier ja was soll ich eine ahnung
toulouse soldiers frage man schaut gar nicht habe ich habe ganz viele sachen ganz viele fixes für
unsere aktuelle unsere aktuelle software unsere aktuelle software
oder auch etwas anders das will ich
die chevy pickt unter anderem und geklärt warum da was ist und wieder was
ist und das kaputt geht und solche dinger diese moistur kugel nervt die krist deIt ist echt
lebensmüde der typ ich sollte da nicht hinterher rennen war total bescheuert dem Ganze jetzt hinterher
Beschäftigst du dich mit Python?
Selten mache ich was.
Selten.
Bist du IT-Chef deiner Firma?
Nein.
Wo sind denn hier überhaupt Gegner?
Da oben.
Da kann ich jetzt als Horisser aber noch nicht hin.
Ich bin langsam.
Bestes Schild.
Bestes Schild aller Zeiten.
Leute, ich kann nicht.
Ich glaube, ich mache aus.
Ich kann nicht spielen heute.
Ich bin total
Brain-AFK.
Ich realisiere kaum, wo Gegner sind.
Hast du schon mal
das MMO gezockt, was der Friseur24
spielt? Ja, hab ich.
Ich hab da sogar einen
Level 59er Wizard,
der ganz gut ausgerüstet ist.
Was macht ihr für Software?
Finanzkram.
Ich meine, warum stehe ich hier rum?
Das ist einfach total dumm.
Was?
Was mache ich denn hier überhaupt?
Was ist das für ein Arsch, ey?
Ich bin so komplett nicht bei der Sache.
Scheiß drauf.
Ich muss jetzt switchen.
Wenn ich mit der Horisser da bin, ist der Punkt verloren.
Guck mal, warum habe ich nicht gleich rechts geklickt?
Ich bin so schlecht heute.
Ich bin.
Ich habe gefühlt das Gehirn-Lag von drei Sekunden.
Ich komme überhaupt nicht rein.
Warum habe ich nicht?
Warum habe ich nicht direkt rechts drauf gemacht?
So etwas.
Nichts.
Ja, so ein Fischer sucht man nichts.
Game.
Ja, das ist nur Quickplay.
Das Problem ist, ich kann halt nicht komplett
Gehirn-AFK spielen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Da ist mein eigener Anspruch zu hoch.
Ja, das gute Input-Lag,
bloß dass ich das im Hirn habe.
Dann guckt euch das an.
Ich merke das richtig.
Nach Tagen, wo ich...
Vielleicht liegt das wirklich daran,
dass ich mittlerweile 33 bin.
Keine Ahnung.
Nach Tagen, wo ich gearbeitet habe
und abends noch irgendwie spielen will,
ich bin null fokussiert
und kriege auch nur die Hälfte mit.
Ich meine, hallo.
Kenny, EU West.
Ich habe einen neuen Account gemacht,
weil ich viel zu hoch gerankt bin mit meinem anderen.
Zumindest für das, wie ich gerade spiele.
Das ist nicht, was ich machen kann,
dass ich irgendwie ein bisschen
mehr fokussiert bei der Sache bin.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich sah ja einen Schnitt verkehrt.
Neuen Roadhog muss ich mir auch nochmal angucken.
Zum Glück bist du erst 25, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt,
aber das habe ich schon öfters gemerkt.
Wenn ich irgendwas ernsthaft spielen will
oder allgemein irgendwas ernsthaft machen will,
wo man sich konzentrieren muss nach dem Arbeiten,
ich kriege das einfach nicht hin.
Ich bin voll langsam und alles dann.
Das klappt einfach nicht.
Und das Schlimme ist,
ich merke es,
das ist nicht nur in-game,
also, ne,
wie ich was mitkriege.
Ich merke auch,
dass ich faul bin
und manchmal die Maus gar nicht bewegen will.
Also quasi,
wenn jetzt ein Gegner,
wenn da, da, hier,
da wo der Automat ist,
wenn da jetzt ein Gegner ist
und ich ziehe jetzt da hin,
dann mache ich quasi,
oder,
dann mache ich lieber so,
bis ich drüber bin,
anstatt so.
Wisst ihr?
Total bescheuert.
Obwohl es viel schlechter ist
und viel langsamer.
Einfach, weil ich faul wie Sau bin
an so einem Tag.
Ach, man kann ja jetzt verheilen,
wenn man...
Ja, wir gehen jetzt einfach rein.
Ja, das klappt so nicht.
Ja.
Das ist, ja,
das war früher nicht so schlimm.
Früher war ich unter der Woche,
ich, keine Ahnung,
Schule arbeitete,
war ein Schwurscht,
da war ich danach noch fit
bis 22 Uhr,
war überhaupt kein Ding.
Jetzt bin ich so voll,
voll weggetreten irgendwie.
Wochenende und so,
vor allem,
wenn ich ausgeschlafen habe,
ist kein Problem.
Ich meine, guck,
warum habe ich den Hook
jetzt nicht getroffen?
Das ist, das war,
das einfachste Tag
in aller Zeit.
Und warum laufe ich hier
alleine rein
und warum kommt keiner mit?
Das liegt nicht,
das liegt nicht nur dran,
weil es Quickplay ist.
Das liegt nicht nur dran,
weil es Quickplay ist,
es liegt einfach daran,
weil ich
sacke wie Sau gerade.
Aber richtig.
Äh.
Siehst du,
und jetzt,
ich habe auch das Problem,
dass ich jetzt quasi gar nicht weiß,
was ich nehmen soll.
Das ist,
das ist mir früher
alles nicht passiert.
Da habe ich
Tab gemacht,
weil instant klar,
was gepickt werden muss,
alles gut.
Vielleicht sollte ich
wirklich bloß,
noch Wochenende
spielen und streamen,
beziehungsweise
spielen im Stream
und
unter der Woche
irgendwas anderes machen.
Streamtechnisch.
Moment.
Hatten die gerade
einen Gegner zu wenig?
Guck,
ich war,
ich war gerade sogar zu faul,
mich umzudrehen.
Hä?
Was?
Hoba Hans, danke.
Was war denn das jetzt gerade
für ein, für ein Game?
Ich merke das auch,
dass ich,
die Maus nicht richtig bewegen will,
dass ich immer nur so kleine,
so kleine Sachen,
so kleine Bewegungen
mit der Maus mache,
weil ich sie nicht bewegen will.
Normalerweise musst ihr halt
einfach mal,
zack, da bist du auch
beim Genji hinterher.
Ja, Singleplayer
wäre wahrscheinlich besser.
Aber was?
Sagt keiner Call of Duty.
Das halte ich nicht aus.
Oh, ich muss,
ich muss euch das mal kurz zeigen.
Ich gehe mal kurz Training Range.
Das ist,
das ist wirklich ganz,
ganz schlimm.
Das,
das Problem hatte ich früher nicht.
Normalerweise,
so,
oh, Soldier.
Normalerweise,
wenn ich den jetzt treffen will,
ne,
dann,
jetzt würde ich irgendwie
sowas hier machen,
so, weil ich zu faul,
ich, ich würde quasi meine Maus
minimal bewegen,
würde es so machen.
Und wenn da oben einer ist,
normalerweise musst du halt,
wenn Genji an dir vorbeidäscht,
machst du halt den da.
Dann machst du halt,
machst du halt deine Maus rüber.
Aber nee,
ich mache sowas hier.
Sowas.
Was ist das hier?
Wie beschissen kann man sein?
Warum mache ich sowas,
anstatt hier einfach mal
die Maus ordentlich rüber zu schieben?
Oder anstatt,
ne,
ich, ich, ich,
ich strafe dann lieber
wie der letzte Depp,
anstatt hier einfach mal
rüber zu zielen und sowas.
Ich bin einfach mega faul.
Und dann kann das auch nichts werden.
Oh.
Ist wirklich so.
Das, das mache ich,
das mache ich gar nicht.
Obwohl ich weiß,
okay, Genji ist jetzt an der Seite,
würde ich niemals hier den da machen,
weil es wäre zu anstrengend,
jedes einmal was Maus-Pads zu fahren.
Stahl beknackt.
Vielleicht muss ich einfach mal was futtern.
Hups.
Doch, ich, ich hole mir mal was zu essen.
Vielleicht wird es dann besser.
Ähm, Sam Fischer,
ich spiele mal eine Runde alleine kurz.
Gerade schnell was geholt.
Social Eating.
Tula Solders fragt,
würdest du gerne so lange leben,
wie du willst?
Ja, klar.
So lange, wie ich will,
ist das gut.
Für immer garantiert nicht.
Für immer nicht.
Aber so ein paar hundert Jahre oder so.
So mal und so gucken,
wie sich das alles entwickelt.
Da wäre ich dabei.
Ja, vielleicht soll ich besser,
wirklich besser auf Singleplayer-Games
umschwenken unter der Woche.
Einfach zu im Arsch.
Bam!
! Bam!
WTF?
Äh, Heal? Heal? Heal?
Gibt's nicht.
Äh, was ist denn das hier wieder?
Da bleibt mir gar nichts anderes übrig,
wie hier irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
Soldier oder sonst was zu spielen.
Haha, Los Soldiers, ja, das kenne ich noch.
Ne, Anne?
Nein, nein, nicht Anne, Anna.
Links flankt irgendwas rum.
Debated?
Nein!
Aber ich hab's noch, Mädel.
Gut, dass da Genji reingesprungen ist.
Honzo!
Hanzo!
Dann sind schon wieder alle tot.
Ich warte mal auf meine Leute.
Echt.
Krieg ich ein Heal oder so?
Irgendwas?
Es geht mit Blitz ab!
Ich muss High Ground und dann wird reingeultet.
Kann der sich mal muten, der Typ?
Dum, dum, dum, dum.
Auf!
Eigentlich wäre es viel besser, ich laufe hinten rum, so.
Da wäre ich jetzt schneller dran.
Egal.
Hast du einen 144-Hertz-Monitor?
Ja, ja, ja, hab ich.
Außerdem springe ich zu viel mit Soldier.
Ich muss mehr strafen.
Warte!
Pfff!
Das Schlimme ist, wisst ihr,
weil man weiß, was man verkehrt macht
und es trotzdem nicht macht.
Ich muss den Typen muten, der nervt mich.
Wie mutet man überhaupt Leute?
So.
Ups.
Auf.
Bumm, bumm, bumm.
Nein.
Ich treff nicht.
Komm mal her.
Ich heile dich, Hanzo.
Hanzo, ich heile dich.
Komm mal her.
Ich könnte jetzt mal nach oben gehen.
Eigentlich könnte ich mal nach oben gehen.
Tröedo gammelt da schon rum.
Der Hanzo!
Voll.
Ach, das stört mich nicht, dass ich 55 Führer habe.
Ist ja auch gerade zum Einschlafen, ne?
Okay, die haben...
Sniper.
Was ist denn hier rechts los?
Oh!
Weg hier.
Na, super.
Okay, wir contesten nicht.
Oh, ich bin so im Arsch, ey.
Ich kann nicht spielen.
Eigentlich könnte ich mich jetzt hinsetzen und irgendwelche YouTube-Videos gucken, aber das war's.
Ich glaube, mit dem Multiplayer strebst du auch noch eine Woche.
Das lasse ich bleiben.
Wahrscheinlich habe ich drei.
Nein.
29 Prozent.
Null.
Signing Stream.
Ne.
Ich habe ja erst gelesen.
Singing Stream.
Aber vorhin hat jemand geschrieben Signing Stream.
Social Leading Stream.
Ja, mache ich ja schon gerade.
Who lost soldiers?
Ich werde nicht heiraten.
Ich verstehe den Sinn von heiraten.
Nee, nicht.
Außer, dass es saumäßig viel Geld kostet, sollte man sich wieder scheiden lassen.
Wo die Chancen sehr hoch sind.
Statistisch gesehen.
Und jeder denkt natürlich, ah, bei mir passiert das nicht.
Repair your defenses.
Ja, weniger Steuern.
Select your view.
Aber, also, alleine wegen den Steuern zu heiraten ist ja schon mal das erste Problem.
Also der erste Fail.
Und, ähm, wenn das mal in die Hose geht, dann wirst du mehr Kohle, vor allem, wenn du noch Kinder in die Welt gesetzt hast in der Zeit, dann wirst du ja mehr Kohle los, als du da jemals gespart hast mit Steuern.
Und, wie gesagt, die Chancen sind gar nicht so, statistisch gesehen, nicht wirklich gering.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Ehen heute geschieden werden wird, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, wir sind locker schon bei jeder Zweite.
Ja gut, zusammen wohnen kann man machen.
Solange man, hm?
Also man muss ja dafür nicht heiraten.
Das spricht ja nichts dagegen.
Ey, wie gefällt mir das Charakterdesign von Moira nicht?
Mal roll dich aus.
So. Spammen wir mal dahinter.
Oh Max, jetzt sei mal nicht so faul mit deiner Mausbewegung, Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Ich bin doch keine 80.
Warum sterben die schon alle hier wieder? WTF?
Point.
Danke.
Junkrat, danke.
Lol.
Okay, was macht der Typ da vorne?
Komm her, Hanzo.
Hanzo.
Ah.
Ich hör links was.
Hat uns da was geflankt oder so?
Soll ich da jetzt mit vor?
Das ist einfach beknackt.
Also, der Spielfluss hier, den check ich net.
Das wird so hoch.
WTF? Was ist das? Was geht hier?
Ja, keine Ahnung, was da abgeht.
Das sind die Games.
Ist die Quote bei gebildeten Menschen wirklich nicht so hoch?
Es kann sein, gebildete Menschen überlegen sich wahrscheinlich dreimal, ob sie heiraten.
Lass doch schilden.
Moment, wo sind die Gegner?
Ich renne jetzt einfach mit vor.
Scheint ja gerade voll angesagt zu sein.
Was?
Das hört sich an wie so ein...
Wie so ein Kocher.
Die, der Zauber von...
Dieser Attack-Zauber von Moira.
Wie so ein Wasserkocher.
Max, warum bewegst du deine Maus nicht ordentlich, um Genji zu verfolgen?
Warum, warum machst du hier die, die, die Spar-Variante hier?
Schießt auf mich.
Danke.
Achtung, wenn die hier durchkommen, also...
Huge.
Huge Ult machen wir jetzt.
Huge Ult.
Da kommt keiner durch. Auch gut.
Ich dachte, da kommen jetzt mehr durch.
Normalerweise kommen da auf einmal mehr durch.
Aber...
Gut.
Die machen das genauso planlos, wie wir.
Huge Ult.
Schieß mich an!
Please!
Oh oh.
Siehste?
Einmal nicht aufgepasst.
Brain-AFK.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind.
Richtig, richtig dumm wieder gewesen.
Warum habe ich da vorne gestanden?
Richtig hängengeblieben.
Ich bin ja Brain-AFK.
Warum treffe ich den Kopf von der Pharah nicht?
Man weiß es nicht.
Oh.
Soll ich jetzt da wirklich mit vor?
Guck mal.
Und außerdem, Max, musst du dich mal wieder angewöhnen, Bursts zu schießen.
Äh.
Ups.
Moment, das war ein Rechtsklick, oder?
Ich sage euch Leute, das war ein Rechtsklick.
Ne, war es nicht.
Fühlst du dich manchmal innerlich leer?
Alter!
Was sind das für Fragen?
Heute Mittag habe ich mich innerlich leer gefühlt.
Da war ich bei Fletchers Better Burger danach.
Na?
Was ist denn das?
Warst du hier manuschein und glaubst dich nicht leicht?
Da war ich bei Fletchers Better Burger danach.
Na!
Hahaha.
Habe ich mich selbst gegillt.
Nahmen.
Wollte hier Cafreek 2.0 machen an den Typen.
Wo ist eigentlich der Payload?
Ach.
Dahinten ist der Payload.
Require healing.
Oh mit dem Reaper.
Ja das.
Acht.
Ich somehow habe das Gefühl, die Gegner rennen ist es hier so was wie auf der Messe,
wo man einfach random Thank you health überfordert.
irgendwas bashen kann so auf dem schießstand
ne chris die habe ich noch nicht also doch habe ich habe ich aber ich finde
das mit recoil anzeige besser er will mich hocken
und eben nicht getroffen die frage gesagt innerlich leer habe ich mich
heute mit nach gefühlt aber richtig innerlich leer und dann gab es mit
doppelt fleisch dann war ich nicht mehr leer
was für eine erkenntnistheorie brauchen wir jetzt aber echt philosophisch ich
will jetzt zusammen apps entwickeln und erfolgreich werden
hast du eine gute idee für eine app hast du richtig richtig krasse idee da können wir
drüber reden fühlst du dich von veganern getriggert
kommt drauf an ob sie es darauf anlegen wenn sie mich in ruhe lassen nicht und
nur weil einer vegan ist juckt mich das auch nicht großartig
aber
wenn leute anfangen ein versuchen zu überzeugen
das ist alles schlechtes was man macht und das erste das einzige wahre da geht
es mir auf den sack der tool of socials hast du schon hast
du schon paar apps entwickelt ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung von android
entwicklung aber kann mir mittlerweile auch mit z Minecraft machen
da erkennt man nicht die sprache weil in java werde ich nicht programmieren das gebe ich mir nicht
Das gebe ich mir nicht.
Heute Viewer Games.
Ja, hatte ich eigentlich vor.
Aber ich fühle mich gerade nicht in der Lage,
dem Spielgeschehen einigermaßen zu folgen.
Deswegen heute eher nicht.
Hallo Schere Nummer 1.
Bester Name.
Moment.
Auf geht's, Winston.
Bam.
Ja, Sonntags von Java und C-Sharp sind relativ ähnlich.
Wobei Java ganz viele merkwürdige Dinge hat.
Weiß nicht, das sagt mir überhaupt nicht zu.
Gar nicht.
Außerdem hat Java mittlerweile ordentliche Generics.
Ich glaube nicht.
No aim, no brain.
Hey, Winston ist der beste, der beste Held, wenn man ihn kann.
Für Leute, die Mechanic-technisch nichts drauf haben.
Also so wie ich.
Wenn man ihn kann.
Also, nicht so.
Also so macht man zum Beispiel das mit Winston nicht.
So macht man das nicht.
Normalerweise springst du rein und dann wartest du, bis du getroffen wirst.
Dann machst du Bubble.
Und so nicht.
Und vor allem wegrennen schon mal gar nicht.
Du musst als Winston immer drauf.
Immer drauf.
LOL.
Und tschüss.
CU.
So, dass er da ist.
Please.
Brauche, brauche Auto.
Alter.
Der Junkrat.
Der nervt.
Overwatch-Kurztipps, na.
Am Wochenende wieder.
Achtung, die schmeißen wir jetzt hier runter, klar.
Hat nicht so ganz funktioniert, ne?
Bescheuert.
Warum neuer Account?
Weil mein Alter zu hoch gerankt ist.
Und ich definitiv nicht mehr.
Weil ich nicht mehr auf dem Rank spiele.
Wow.
Siehste?
Warum hab ich nicht gleich Q gedrückt?
Typischer Brainlag-Fall.
Ich weiß, dass man ohne Mac spawnt.
Ich weiß, dass Soldier mich übel schnell killt.
Warum hab ich nicht einfach Q gedrückt?
Anstatt zu versuchen, drauf zu schießen.
Ne, so ist das.
Ich hab das Gefühl, irgendwas ist hinter uns.
Findest du die neue Mercy eigentlich gut oder scheiße?
Ähm.
Ich hab die...
Ich kenn nur die ganz alte Mercy noch.
Wie gesagt.
Season 4 war das letzte, wo ich ordentlich gespielt hab.
Ich kenn's halt nur aus Streams.
Quasi mit bei Ult.
Quasi zweimal Instant Reds und eigentlich Must Have.
Und weil halt Tempo.
Ähm.
Das, was ich jetzt gesehen hab, ist glaube ich die neue Mercy.
Die hatte so einen Timer beim Reds.
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass Moira Mercy eine gute Kombi ist.
Die wir auf Turnieren sehen werden.
Weil Tempo Reds ist immer noch...
Eigentlich das Entscheidende.
Also sprich, ne.
Du campst.
Einer stirbt von dir und Mercy kann wiederbeleben.
Dann bist du einfach Instant einer mehr.
Pff.
Lol.
Hehehe.
Oh ne.
Ne, ne.
Da kann ich, da kann ich nicht peeken.
Lol.
Jetzt ist hier wieder das Spawnrape angesagt.
Ne, was ich mit den Mercy Reds meine, ist halt mal angenommen.
Du campst, es stirbt bei dir einer und du wirst ja bei dem Fight auch jemand killen.
Es ist selten, dass kompletter Vibe ist, wo keiner stirbt vom anderen Team.
Und du kannst wiederbeleben.
Da bist du, hast du dann Instant wieder einen mehr.
Und du musst nichts dafür machen, außer, außer eine Taste drücken bei Mercy.
Das ist das, was ich meine.
Nix gerissen.
Carried.
Get carried.
Äh, non but happy, einfach üben.
Ist leichter gesagt als getan, aber...
Wichtig ist, finde ich...
Dass man selbst mit sich unzufrieden ist und selbst merkt, wenn man Scheiße baut.
Auch wenn's, wenn's echt frustrierend ist.
Also quasi...
Das, was mir alle 5 Sekunden aktuell auffällt.
Manchmal bin ich da auch so überkritisch.
Aber kacke spielen nervt mich.
Also, kacke spielen nervt mich selbst, glaub ich, am meisten.
Und man selbst sieht ja auch noch viel mehr.
Na, bei deinem Teammate siehst du's ja nur von außen, aber wenn du selbst spielst, siehst du ja viel mehr, was du für eine Scheiße baust.
Welche Helden müssen deiner Meinung nach gebufft werden?
Kann ich nix zu sagen.
Ich muss erst mal wieder in das Game reinkommen.
Und wieder ein bisschen ranked spielen und alles.
Wobei, gebufft...
Was haben wir denn da?
Also Sachen, was halt aktuell...
Was halt überhaupt nicht gespielt wird.
Symmetra muss beispielsweise nicht gebufft werden.
Ist situationsabhängig, vielleicht ein bisschen, aber...
Situationsabhängige Helden sind okay.
Mei, zum Beispiel, wird halt relativ wenig gespielt.
Anna müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich finde, der Rest kann im Großen und Ganzen so bleiben.
Es soll...
Man muss halt die Helden nicht immer komplett auf den Kopf stellen.
Mercy soll...
Sollte, finde ich...
Grundlegend dahingehend überarbeitet werden,
dass, wenn sie denn eben so stark ist,
dass dazu auch ein bisschen was gehört.
Also, dass man nicht...
Klar, Mercy ist jetzt nicht super easy,
Also, dass man nicht... Klar, Mercy ist jetzt nicht super easy,
quasi so absolut no brain.
Aber es gibt quasi kaum einen anderen Held, der...
Solo Orisa haben wir hier nicht.
Wir brauchen irgendwas, was ein bisschen Mobility hat.
Aber es geht super.
Winston ist top.
Was willst ist denn an Winston nerven?
Winston ist doch gut.
Winston ist der beste Char, wenn man was nicht drauf hat.
Aimtechnisch und sonst was.
Und trotzdem viel reißen will.
Winston.
Counter Tracer Frage.
Eigentlich, wenn man ehrlich ist,
Klar, so was wie Rotor geht natürlich,
Aber eigentlich nix.
Nix so richtig.
Was machen die da vorne?
Ich stell mich jetzt einfach mal hin und halte den rechten Klick.
So, ich geh wieder.
Wow!
Den holen wir.
Hab ich da einen Roadhog gehört?
Nix da? Auch gut.
What?
Whyhook?
Nein!
Ich find, Winston und Tracer,
das geht beinahe so.
Du kannst auch als Tracer einen Winston relativ schnell kaputt machen,
wenn du das gut spielst.
Was hältst du von Rocket League?
Äh.
Also, vom Game hab ich...
Ich hab's nie gespielt.
Was kann man jetzt mal machen?
Das läuft grad so geil.
Moment, haben wir noch einen Heal? Ja, haben wir.
HONSO!
Wer das E-Sport-mäßig spielt,
Rocket League, ja, ja, ja.
Das ist wirklich auf dem aufsteigenden Ast.
Also, ich hab jetzt viele Sachen schon gesehen,
wo Rocket League gespielt wird.
Oh, ich hatte kein Momento mehr.
Ups.
So viel wieder zum Thema Brain-AFK.
Over-Extension of Doom.
Ja, das neue Code auf dem PC ist auch komisch.
Rekt!
Wo ist der hässliche Sniper?
Um rechts, oder?
Ähm, ja.
World War 2 hat auf dem PC
ziemliches Input-Lag.
Und?
Ähm, es ist voll mit Cheatern
mittlerweile schon.
Schrecklich, ey.
Ich werd gleich mal abhauen.
Nee, mach ich nicht.
Kill mich, please.
Was? Kill mich halt!
Oh.
Warte, der Reinhardt da oben.
Äh, okay.
Wir haben gar keinen Healsaw mehr.
Der Reinhardt da oben.
Beste Position, beste Position.
Fahren wir mal im Kreis.
Nein, nein, nein. Leute, Leute.
Der Omni-Healer.
Der ist wirklich weit vorne.
Ich hör links was.
Ist das unserer?
Fuck.
Okay, das war's.
Fast haben wir Old gekriegt.
Hä?
Was?
Nein, oh Mann.
Ja, 60 Overwatch-Comp und Rank
kannst du null vergleichen.
Eine Rede.
Wie es in Rocket League ist,
kann ich schon mal.
Ähm.
Ja, die Singleplayer-Events
vom neuen COD auf dem PC
sind wirklich an die Framerate gebunden.
Das ist total lächerlich.
Es gibt Quicktime-Events
im neuen COD, dann hat man hier so einen Kreis
und quasi hier irgendwo wird dann die Maus angezeigt
und man muss quasi einfach nur den Mauszeiger
in den Kreis ziehen.
Und man hat ungefähr...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kann jetzt schlecht die Zeit...
So, so quasi.
So, so viel Zeit hat man.
Wie der Heldwechsel jetzt dauert, um das zu machen.
Also, also gar nicht.
Stellst du runter,
50 Hertz Monitor
stellst du ein mit V-Sync-Ansatz.
Das Spiel quasi auf 50 FPS begrenzt
ist gar kein Ding.
Easy.
Packt jeder.
Mach mal Werbung.
Für den Stream.
Ja, das stimmt, es hat keine Applaus.
Das macht nichts.
Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Cybergear, weil der andere Account so hoch ist.
Der Main-Account.
Den einen Account weiß ich das Login nicht mehr.
So doof es klingt.
Mein anderer Account ist ja genauso hoch
wie der Main-Account.
Ich habe meinen Main-Account
und meinen Smurf von damals noch.
Die sind beide irgendwie jetzt Season 4 haben wir die ja gespielt.
Irgendwie 3.900 gewesen oder so.
Und den anderen weiß ich nicht mehr.
Moment, ich dachte man kann schießen.
Ah, ne.
Schießen mit Matrix geht nicht.
Oh, ne.
Ich habe gar kein Schiff da gehabt.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wedo.
Null.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Der McCree flankt.
I am moving.
Anjo.
Weiter geht's.
Irgendwie habe ich gedacht, ich höre was da oben.
Habe ich aber nicht.
Ah, Widow.
Lol.
Wir haben keinen Bock zu moven.
Moment, der lebt noch der Genji?
Lebt der noch?
Ne, oder?
Oben links, oben links.
Doch nicht.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Fuck.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
Easy.
Hahaha.
Super.
Das hast du gut gemacht, McCree.
Sehr schön.
Direkt.
Würde ich sagen.
Oh, da gehen wir jetzt hin.
Ich lasse mich heilen.
Oh, ne.
Ah, fuck.
Hätte ich ein bisschen schneller oben gewesen, hättest du beide geownt.
War es das neue Assassin's Creed?
Hat dich überrascht?
Taugt das?
Aber ernsthaft jetzt mal.
Lohnt sich das zu kaufen?
Achtung.
Wir warten jetzt bis Raketen...
Bis Raketen.
Wenn die Raketen wieder da sind, dann gehen wir hoch.
Moment, warum ist der nicht gestorben?
Hahaha.
Lol.
Fuck.
Okay.
Ja, das neue Assassin's Creed wollte ich mal eventuell auch mal anschaffen.
Reaper.
Oh, oh, Achtung.
Der will ulten.
Was ist das für ein Typ, ne?
Perfekt.
Assassin's Creed Fisher.
Ich glaube Mercy wird es weiterhin geben.
Ah, ne.
Du hast ja Mercy drin stehen.
Mercy wird auf jeden Fall...
Ja, Mercy wird auf jeden Fall...
Ja.
weiter gespielt.
Mehr killen kann ich jetzt wirklich nicht gerade.
Wieder hüpft.
Die D.Va macht so krass Damage mit den Raketen
mittlerweile. Wahnsinn.
Was ist mit deinem
zweiten 8700K passiert? Hab ich zurückgeschickt.
Hab ich zurückgeschickt.
Pusherino.
Hui.
Und doch wieder
Overwatch.
Kommt von Overwatch nicht weg.
Overwatch ist einfach ein geiles
Game. Ich sag's
jeden Stream 85, 30 Milliarden
mal, wenn der Rank-Modus nicht so verkackt
wäre,
dann
wäre das das beste Game überhaupt.
Psschuh, psschuh, psschuh.
De, de, de.
Ne.
Finde ich anders, Biestüb.
Es liegt mit an den
Leuten, aber die Leute sind
nur so toxic, wie es das Game zulässt.
Und wie es das Game fördert.
Und leider fördert Overwatch Rank
ganz schön so toxic
Geschichten.
Man kann die,
neben dem ganzen Zeug, was ich immer über Ranked erzähle,
eines der größten Probleme,
die mir damals auch schon auf den Sack
gegangen sind, wie gesagt, diesen 4 war das
letzte, wo ich so nicht aktiv gespielt habe, ist einfach
du kannst
die Matches, die wirklich
ausgeglichen
sind, kannst du an einer
Hand abzählen. 20% der Matches sind
ausgeglichen.
Dann gibt es die Matches, die wo drüber
gerutscht wird, über einen oder mal
über den Gegner. Oder die
Matches, die von den Stats so aussehen,
als ob es knapp gewesen
wäre, aber nie knapp waren.
Äh.
Äh. Nope.
Auch wenn es Quickplay ist.
Da habe ich jetzt gerade keinen Nerv drauf gehabt.
Ja, Suncore
Spasten gibt es überall.
Toxic Rumgeflaming gibt es auch überall.
Überall, wo es eine Ladder gibt. Überall, wo es
Rank gibt. Keine Frage.
Es ist die Frage, wie sich das auswirkt.
Nur rumnerven.
Im Chat. Ja. Und halt
sich anstellen und
den Leuten gibt es da ab und zu mal welche, die
feeden. Das ist alles okay.
Aber in Overwatch hat das System
so von
Trollpick, äh, Trollpick
Symmetra Mains
zu, ähm,
Leuten, die quasi mit One Trick,
Linksklick, Mercy, Grandmaster geworden
sind.
Die, die es noch nicht
mal Toxic meinen, sind sie ja auch
an sich von ihrer Einstellung her nicht.
Ähm.
Aber das fördert das Ganze
halt noch, ja. Dann ragen
die Leute, die eh schon in so
Toxic veranlagt sind, noch mehr rum.
Und dazu
kommt halt eben, dass die Spiele nicht ausgeglichen sind.
20% der Spiele sind vielleicht ausgeglichen.
Der Rest ist, ist
aufregend. Ja. Und wenn
quasi zu, zu Toxic
Leuten, die es in jedem Spiel,
gibt, auch in jedem Spiel mit Ranked,
ganz klar, wenn dann auch so
quasi, quasi die Rahmenbedingungen
das Ganze noch irgendwie fördern
und dazu führen, dass man
na, man könnte ja über die
Toxic Leute hinwegsehen, wenn das Spiel
unglaublich geil wäre und Spaß machen würde,
ähm, weil alles andere
passt, dann wäre das ja überhaupt kein Ding.
Und das Spiel im Kern
ist ja auch geil.
Halt den Rank nicht.
Hahaha. Two Lost Soldiers.
Ja. Würde ich mir drüber Gedanken,
machen. Würde ich mir drüber
Gedanken machen. Kommt
natürlich auf die Bezahlung an.
Du meinst, wenn du mit deiner Android-App
dann die ersten Millionen gemacht hast?
Two Lost Soldiers.
Und Orisa, die F.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich als Solo-Tank spielen
soll. Winston. Nein. Aber Winston
als Solo-Tank. Ja, wir haben, wir hätten eigentlich
genug hier. Komm.
Speed. Oh, wir haben Lucio.
Wieder D.Va. Mir bleibt mir gar nichts anderes übrig,
gerade. Keine Pharah am Start.
Okay.
Ich habe es gar nicht geschafft, alle Raketen
zu verfehlen.
Ich brauche
mein Auto wieder.
Gibt es nicht.
Ah, ich habe 4 DPS abgelenkt. Mehr konnte ich nicht machen.
Ja, Peace-Typ, das stimmt.
Wobei, das geht
auf höheren Rängen.
Also, da hast du auch genug
Leute, die Tanks spielen. Na, wobei, Tank
vielleicht weniger.
Die, die auch Support spielen.
Ach.
Durch.
Also, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen,
sag mal,
ich finde, LOL scheint, so, ich habe, ich spiele
es nicht, ja. Aber LOL scheint ein gutes
Ranking-System zu haben.
Können wir regroupen?
Können wir gehen? Please.
Oh, der Reaper.
Alter.
Also, das Ranking-System von LOL macht wirklich einen
brauchbaren Eindruck.
Rekt.
Oh, falsch,
in die falsche Richtung gesprungen.
Ich brauche mein Auto. Wo ist mein Auto?
Ah, ich brauche mein Auto wieder.
Auto.
Heal-Peace, Heal-Peace.
Und ich finde auch, dass die,
wo wir gerade noch bei Ranking und so sind,
ich finde auch, die Patches sind viel zu langsam.
Da musst du, musst du drauf reagieren.
Ich weiß nicht, muss ich das mal angucken?
In Dota 2 kriegen sie das ja auch alles hin.
Klar, da gibt es auch Toxics.
Leute, klar, da wird auch geflamed.
Klar, da gibt es auch ein Meta.
Wobei, dass es ein Meta gibt, nicht schlimm, was es ist.
Wird es immer geben.
Aber es ist alles mal eine Ecke weniger nervig.
Ich werde jetzt Diva-Main.
Easy.
Mit null Medaillen.
Rekt.
Achtung, die wird jetzt geowned.
Sobald hier einer durchkommt, wird er gebasht.
Nein.
Gibt es nicht.
Die kriegen mich nicht tot.
Es war ein bisschen,
ein bisschen overextended.
Ein bisschen, ganz genau.
Moin, Koopa.
Heal-Bees, Heal-Bees, Heal-Bees.
Oh, oh, oh, ich muss raus.
Nope, Genji, nope.
Oh, nee.
Ich meine, das ist gut.
Ihr konzentriert euch auf mich. Alles gut.
Moment, was haben die, haben die eingenommen?
Das ist jetzt schlecht.
Das ist jetzt schlecht. Jetzt können sie mich ownen.
Nope, Genji ist auch nicht.
Siehst du nicht in 5 Jahren?
2 Millionen Abos.
Genau.
Play of the game.
Haha.
Ja.
Genau.
Ich cover dann den Katja-Krasser-Witze-Song.
Mit 2 Millionen Abos.
Der Friseur findet den übelst geil.
So war es auch angemerkt.
Also nicht Katja-Krasser-Witze,
bei, keine Ahnung,
sondern den Song.
Aber bitte oben ohne, klar.
Nackt.
Mit dem Kaboom zusammen.
Den Krieger lassen wir auch nackig durchs Bild rennen.
Äh, wir haben als erstes 2 Support-Picks.
Oh, glaub ich.
Yeah.
Ich warte mal kurz, was da noch so kommt.
Ähm.
Der schreit so ein bisschen nach Reinhardt,
aber Reinhardt ohne ordentlichen Support ist schwierig.
Komm, scheiß drauf.
Ja, ich, ich weiß nicht.
Ich werd mit Rohtok.
Hallo.
Rohtok.
Also mit dem neuen Rohtok bin ich noch gar nicht warm geworden.
Und mit Rohtok als Solo-Tank find ich es auch.
Äh, whatever you like.
Immer schwierige Sachen.
Einen ordentlichen Tank brauchste.
Äh, oh.
Oh.
Why can't I really play those things?
Okay.
Da ist einer rübergegangen.
Oh, wir haben eine Widow am Start.
Weiß nicht, wo die ist.
Warum mach ich meinen Firestrike eigentlich gar nicht?
WTF?
Oh.
Kannst ja mal probieren.
Muss als Reinhardt Ult-Charge sammeln.
Ist das Wichtigste.
Muss ich nicht killen lassen, nicht killen lassen, nicht killen lassen.
Oh, fuck.
Wip.
Heilen wir uns mal.
Eigentlich muss man hier nicht fighten.
Lol.
Jetzt.
Huge Shatter.
Muss ich gar nicht shattern.
Achtung.
Trick 17.
Oh.
Hex Sword.
So.
Weg.
Nein.
Warum?
Warum hätte ich genanoboostet?
Oh Mann.
Dachte ich mir.
Scheiß drauf.
Haust jetzt den Shatter raus.
Ich mein, kommt ja eh nix.
Und zack sind sie am Start.
Richtig dumm.
Ich hab den ewig aufgehoben.
Womit wir dann dabei sind.
Keine Ahnung, wer jetzt den los raushauen.
Hätte ich den aufgehoben, ne?
Es war klar, der Genji kommt mit Blade an.
Ah, fuck.
Ich hab kein Schild gehabt.
Fuck.
Oh.
Mach die platt.
Die ist, die ist doch schon tot.
Die.
Die Orisa.
Ja, gut.
Ich glaub links rum ist schneller, oder?
Ich glaub links rum.
War links rum nicht schneller?
Bongos.
Hopp.
Alter, dieser, dieses Ding.
Dieses Ding.
Was ist das?
Das Teil.
Oh, jetzt können wir contesten.
Wir haben aber keinen Bock.
Können wir contesten?
Oh nee.
Ist das ein Pro-Reinhardt?
Dieser Ball, dieser Ball, der fuckt mich so ab.
Äh, ah.
So im Rank-Wert ist das typische, lul, DPS, Saga, I have gold medal.
Das war so richtig schön toxic ranked Antwort jetzt.
Tja.
Aber die Balls sind wirklich nervig.
Hanzo, du kannst da oben übrigens Scatter reinhauen, ne?
Ich muss Hilfe, ich brauch Hilfe.
Nein.
Haha, sonst wäre ich eh nicht mehr weggekommen, fuck.
Ähm, was nehmen wir denn mal hier?
Reinhardt bringt es ja nicht so wirklich.
Komm, scheiß drauf, wir bleiben jetzt mal Reinhardt.
Wir müssen halt mal croupen, sonst bringt das nichts.
Aber die pushen auch nicht, ist auch gut.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, keine Chance.
Contesten.
Ah!
BTF.
Pff.
Das war eine schöne Kombo.
Ich glaube zwar irgendwie nicht,
dass die Kombo Absicht war.
Also diese Orisa-Kombo.
Alter, das gibt so eine kacke.
Trenn ich da auch noch rein.
Ne, ist da gar nicht so übel gegen.
Gegen die Widow.
Wo ist sie denn?
Baby Diva?
Oh oh.
Was? Warum ist der Hanzo nicht...
Nein, nein, ich bin der Falle.
Oh!
Also mehr konnte ich jetzt gefühlt am Schluss wirklich nicht machen.
Es gibt es doch nicht, Alter!
Oh je, ihr Güte!
Was hätte ich denn jetzt anders machen sollen?
Ich habe überhaupt, ich habe total den Überblick verloren.
Das hätten wir dreimal gewinnen müssen.
Ich habe total den Überblick verloren zwischendurch.
Ich habe zwischenzeitlich...
Ich hätte schon mal auf die Widow fliegen können,
aber ich habe zwischenzeitlich gar nicht gecheckt, wo sie ist.
Und dann musste ich stallen am Kart.
Ah ja, aber das war doch nicht schlecht.
Es gab viel XP.
Hast du Mario Odyssey gezockt? Ja.
Ne, Donations backen gerade rum.
Ich habe gar nicht mitgekriegt, dass du donatet hast.
Aber ich gucke mal nach.
Der Sibaro hat donated 10 Euro.
Gerade die heise Hauptseite aufgerufen.
Im Top-Thema.
Cheating in Fortnite.
Was? Epic zerrt 14-jähriges Kind vor Gericht.
Mutter läuft Sturm.
Ernsthaft.
Die sollen ihre Spiele mal cheatsicher machen,
anstatt es Kindern zu verklagen.
Vor allem, was will man Cheater verklagen?
Ich meine...
Die bieten ja irgendwie...
Also die, die irgendwelche Hacks anbieten,
kommerziell, okay, verstehe ich. Aber...
Weil du kannst...
Du kannst die...
Na, die haben zwar gegen die Benutzungsbedingungen
von dem Spiel verstoßen, aber...
Hä? Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das...
Vor allem nicht in Deutschland.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das in Deutschland klappt.
Wobei, ist das überhaupt in Deutschland?
Was ist das Friseurspiel?
Das Friseurspiel Black Desert Online.
Hello.
Pay to win MMO.
Na, ja...
Also, wenn man jetzt Pay to Win
in Ja und Nein einsortieren müsste,
dann ist Black Desert schon
bei Ja Pay to Win.
Aber es gibt Schlimmeres.
Das hat schon Pay to Win Aspekte.
Vor allem, wenn man das für das...
Nicht das
Crafting-Material, sondern das, dass man
weniger Material braucht.
Das ist schon Pay to Win.
Dieser Ball.
Moment, was?
Woah.
Heal mich und dann geht's rein.
Easy Rekt.
Wo ist er hin? Bin ich doof?
Wo ist er hin?
Hä?
Manchmal bin ich blind.
Das war bestimmt total obvious,
wo der hin ist.
Oh nein, ein Ticken zu weit links.
Pfuh.
Ein Ticken zu weit links.
Es gibt ein paar Hallen, die werde ich nie spielen.
Das sind unter anderem Hanzo und Mercy.
Der Ball.
Hehe.
Oh, Auto wieder am Start.
Oh, der kommt gut.
Was? Nichts gekillt.
Sammeln wir mal ein bisschen
Ult-Charge.
Kein Heal für dich, Hanzo.
Tu es weg.
Tu es weg. Weiter.
Pusherino.
Wie hoch ist man ranked auf dem Main?
Ich hab Season 4 zuletzt
gespielt.
Der Ball.
Okay, mal aufladen.
Der Doomfist.
But why?
Ist klar.
Hat sich original gedeckt
mit dem Radius bei mir.
Auf dem Main war ich 3900 in der letzten
Season, als ich die PlaySquads gemacht hab.
Ich hab noch
die Fähigkeiten von Doomfist.
Sehr gut.
Oh fuck. Ich hab schon angefangen zu schießen.
Hanzo.
Wollt ihr nicht mal vorkommen, Leute?
Was hat ihn jetzt geheilt?
Ich hab ihn wieder aufgeweckt.
So, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Ah.
Okay, der Zen überlebt immer.
Also.
Ich meine, ich hätte mehr treffen können, ja klar.
Aber da muss einfach nur einer noch mit auf den Zen
schießen, dann ist er kaputt.
Ich brauch diese Mele-Combo, muss ich noch reinkriegen.
So, easy.
Nice.
Ah.
Welche Level haben wir jetzt eigentlich?
Neun Ults.
Das ist ordentlich.
So, mal gucken.
Die Runde machen wir noch.
Also, ich bin wirklich zufrieden mit meinem neuen Rechner.
Konstante.
300 FPS. Easy Clap.
Keine Physik für das Objekt
hier. Ich bin enttäuscht, Blizzard.
Blitz 8.
Oder wie manche sagen auf Reddit,
Blitztacht.
Oh! Wie viele sind denn hier drinnen?
Das ist nicht mit gerecht, dass auf unserer Seite
da einer drinsteht.
Aber wir haben einen zu wenig, okay.
Nope. Da müssen wir jetzt gar nicht rein.
Ich bin so
scheiße heute. Ich bin einfach so schlecht.
Was, wieso nicht 4K? Was 4K?
Ja, ich habe noch 4K.
Ich habe mir was Sinnloses geholt von Amazon.
Ich muss OP.
No Aim Charge spielen, dann geht das.
Ich habe wieder meine Raketen vergessen.
Ah!
Ein Reap Saw.
Auto wieder am Start.
Alles muss man selber machen.
No Panjo.
Hahaha.
So Angst. Easy Clap.
Die VL ist halt idiotensicher.
Das mit den Raketen muss ich mir mal in richtig guten,
äh, in ordentlichen Streams angucken.
Das macht man bestimmt nicht
so beim ranfliegen.
Das macht man bestimmt quasi so vorher zur Hälfte
ranfliegen, ähm,
Mele-Dings, dass du, dass du möglichst viel
möglichst viel Burst hast.
Du musst mal angucken,
wie die Pros das mit den Raketen machen
auf D.Va.
Na, man darf jetzt auf
D.Va auch nicht komplizierter machen, als es ist.
Was genau habe ich mir geholt?
Eine SSD, eine Lampe, ähm,
ja, Doomfist. Da vorne kann dir
keiner helfen, ne?
Will, please?
Ich dachte eigentlich,
da bleibt er stehen. Aber, nope.
Ja, eine SSD für den Server.
Ich will die 60 GB Intel SSDs
raus haben.
Ich habe mir jetzt eine günstige 240 GB bestellt.
Oh, fuck.
Schieß mich nicht an, please.
Please anschießen.
Ui.
An!
Oh, ne.
Da kannst du nichts machen.
Die Fahrer sind voll gold.
Fahrer, na gut, wir haben, wir haben
eine Queen, eine Anna.
Ich kann da auch was gegen machen.
Also eigentlich dürfte die Fahrer nicht zu allzu viel kommen.
So mag ich das.
Teamplay.
Tracer, du musst ihn jetzt noch einmal hitten.
Ohp. Auto.
Na, super.
Kannst nichts machen.
Ok, jetzt haben wir's.
Jetzt müssen wir nur drauf und nicht alle am Tire sterben.
Wo wir grad beim Thema sind.
Ich hätte ulten sollen.
Konnte man jetzt noch nicht wissen, dass wir ihn so verrecken.
Ich dachte mir, fürs nächste Engage haben wir es vielleicht wieder.
Oh.
Moment, wir gewinnen das noch.
What?
Oder?
Quickplay is so random.
Ah, Hardcore-Scene 1 war das.
Oh Mann.
Ich bin rumgesprungen.
Ich will mein Auto wieder.
Will er sterben?
Fuck, ich dachte, ich komme raus.
Oh.
Gutes Play.
Richtig gutes Play.
Sound ist asynchron.
Oh nein.
Nicht schon wieder dieser Scheiß, ey.
Ich mache jetzt die Runde noch fertig.
Sound asynchron.
Weiß nicht, was das für eine Kacke ist.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das dann erst nach 2 Stunden auftritt.
Ich muss doch wieder im Fenstermodus spielen.
Ah.
GG Eats.
Bis.
Dann.
Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.